A couple updates that I thought
you might be interested in:
U.S.
District Court in San Juan just
dismissed the case of 7,000
Viequense who had filed a suit
against the federal government,
the Department of the Navy,
seeking compensation for
damages to their island and
their health.
So that this suit has been in
the making for about seven
years, and it will be appealed.
Also the Ebling case that you
may have read about in Green
Intelligence,
the two young children that
claimed exposure to pesticides
at a very young age.
That is going to trial in
August now, it was just
announced, after ten years.
So this should give you pause
to think about the effect and
cost of litigation.
In terms of TSCA Reform,
TSCA Reform was just introduced
into both the House and the
Senate,
in the Senate by Senator
Lautenberg,
in the House by Henry Waxman.
And for the first time in
nearly twenty-five years,
there's some anticipation that
there will be serious reform of
the way that commercial
chemicals are regulated in the
country.
The chemical companies,
curiously,
are motivated to seek changes
in this law,
because if products that they
make in this country are not
tested to the same standard as
product testing requirements in
Europe,
then U.S.
chemicals will not be allowed
to be sold in Europe.
So that chemical companies are
extremely concerned about the
idea of harmonizing law between
the U.S.
and the European Union.
Cape Wind has not been decided,
but there really appears to be
no clear direction on the part
of Ken Salazar at this point.
You should keep your eyes open
for that over the next week or
so.
And a diesel update.
We talked about diesel exhaust
and we talked about the health
consequences of particulate
matter.
But there is new evidence that
was released quite recently by
Nadine Unger,
who is going to be a new
assistant professor here next
year who has worked with the
Columbia University and NASA on
the effect of particles.
And it's kind of a curious
effect that particles of one
form,
especially those that are
attached to organic matter,
tend to have a reflective
effect to radiation.
So it basically may have a
cooling effect,
whereas black carbon itself
tends to absorb the radiation,
which would have a warming
effect.
So it's interesting.
Diesel exhaust has been
fingered, identified as one of
the key sources of black carbon
in the atmosphere that we need
to pay much more attention to
for its warming effect on
climate.
Happy Earth Day.
Forty years ago today,
Earth Day occurred.
And your parents and I probably
remember it pretty well.
I was in Philadelphia at the
time.
And it was really an
interesting and highly confused
time to be a college student.
And what was interesting about
it is that it was a period of
collision between different
social movements that really had
a core based in universities.
And the collision was among the
anti-war movement,
the civil rights movement,
as well as the environmental
movement.
Nobody really knew what that
meant at the time,
but sitting in Philadelphia,
living in Philadelphia,
watching the yellow sunsets
that occurred every evening
because of the filthy air.
And rowing on the Schuylkill
River with the crew team having
to scrape the globules of slime
and material chemical wastes
that were deposited legally into
the Schuylkill River really was
an unhappy experience.
So really, it was also the dawn
of the modern era of
environmental law in the nation.
And the Clean Air Act
revisions, the Clean Water Act
revisions,
the 1970s were really a time
when great energy was put into
the design of environmental law.
And there was great expectation
on the part of people that had
worked in these movements too
that environmental quality would
change quite radically.
So I wanted to reflect with you
today about imagining an ideal
society.
We think that we're facing many
very severe problems.
And one of the themes of this
course has been to try to help
you judge the effectiveness and
potential of environmental law
to shape behavior so that people
will behave more responsibly
toward the environment and
protect human health and protect
scarce natural resources.
So for a moment,
I'd like you to kind of step
back away from your perception
of all the problems that we
face.
And instead,
to have you imagine an ideal
society.
So what would it look like?
Well, environmental law really
targets itself toward damages.
So knowledge is really a
critical element of it.
And the knowledge that's
necessary in order for it to be
effective is quite complex.
So in the ideal world,
you would want to have perfect
knowledge of externalities,
perfect predictive capacity.
What's the effect of my
behavior going to be?
You'd want to have an efficient
system for compensation for
damages, because all damages
could never be avoided.
You'd also want to have a
literate public,
a public that was capable of
understanding the technical
information at a level of detail
that would make them potentially
effective participants in
decision making.
So literacy,
the capacity to learn,
is a really important component
of this.
You would want to have
governmental authority and the
resources to regulate.
So not only the right to
regulate that would be
authorized by Congress or a
Parliament, but also the
resources to regulate.
And those don't normally go
hand in hand.
So that you often get the
passage of a law,
but you don't get the
allocation of resources.
So there's the authorization of
money that's necessary,
then there's the appropriation
of money that's necessary.
And then EPA or whoever the
agency is have to actually
expend the money in order to
have an effective response.
In an ideal society,
I'd say also that we need to
pay, we would be paying
attention to the most
vulnerable.
They would be identified and
they would be protected by
statute.
There would be equal protection
for all.
And I'll talk more about
inequality in environmental law
in a few moments.
And we would have figured out
how to manage natural resources,
such as our forests,
our soils, our wildlife,
in a sustainable way.
And it's quite interesting.
When we use the word
sustainability,
I tend to cringe.
It's not my favorite word.
I think it's ambiguous and I
think it is used way too
loosely.
But where it seems to be
clearest and have provided a
model for effective law has been
with respect to managing
resources such as forests,
fisheries, where you can
monitor a population,
you can monitor its rate of
growth,
its reproductive success.
So that thinking about
sustainable management of
natural resources has been in
some instances a success story.
I think I would imagine a
stable climate as well.
So I wanted to have you think
with me also about what's been
successful?
What can we point to as success
stories?
And I think that a number of
the cases,
I chose the cases quite
deliberately for this course,
and a number of them
demonstrate the potential of law
to control behavior,
to achieve some of these
objectives.
And I think clearly,
the wilderness protection
system and the national park
system that we have in the
United States really is the envy
of many nations in the world.
So that we have effectively set
aside lands and we've restricted
human access and certain
behaviors and extraction rights
in these areas.
And that really has been quite
a successful policy.
Our national seashores I think
represent a really far-sighted
approach that were meant to
provide recreational
opportunities in the coastal
zone.
But as I mentioned in the
lecture on looking at Cape Cod
and Fire Island and Padre Island
and Point Reyes,
the fact that the government
went into those areas and bought
them,
or consolidated federal
ownership, is going to restrict
future development in a way that
will reduce long-term costs
associated with sea level rise
and increased storm damage.
The Adirondack Park strikes me
as also being a real success
story in many ways.
For me, it really represents a
model for regulating private
land use in the vicinity of
highly valuable public lands.
And remember this park was set
aside back in the 1870s.
So that the Adirondack Park
Agency concept was really
designed initially to protect
what they thought of as
biological diversity,
ecological diversity as well as
integrity,
whatever that meant at the
time, back in 1972,
when the Park Agency statute
was passed.
But almost inadvertently,
they had designed an energy
conservation plan that really
was quite remarkable.
Remember this idea that you
regulate and demand very large
lot sizes in the remote areas.
And then you basically take
away the density requirements in
the towns and villages.
There are really no urban
centers in the Adirondacks.
But this open space
preservation and incentive to
increase density in the existing
areas that already are developed
and have infrastructure,
have roads, have electric
lines, et cetera,
it really is remarkable.
So in terms of an energy
conservation strategy that one
might embed into a land use
plan, it really was very
innovative.
They also used the idea of
transferable development rights
in the Adirondacks that I think
is a very cool idea.
There's a parallel here to the
idea of setting up these
ecosystem service banks.
So I wanted to give you the
example of a windmill,
we talked about wind energy the
other day.
I want to give you the idea
that supposing you had property
next to a windmill and you
thought that you were being
adversely affected by that.
Is there a way that you might
be compensated that would
prevent you from litigating,
that might make you more
accepting of the windmill?
So imagine that you set up a
square around a windmill or a
wind turbine.
And you basically use the
1,000-foot or the 300-meter
distance from any property
boundary that's been recommended
to reduce adverse effects.
So that that would constitute
roughly about a hundred acres.
Well supposing you had a patch
of people that lived adjacent to
that land.
What could you do for them that
might make them more accepting
of it?
Well one thing you could do
would be to provide them with
development rights.
But maybe they didn't want to--
they may not want to develop on
their own property.
So that you could set up a bank
whereby they could deposit these
development rights in that bank
and then somebody who lived in a
receiving zone or purchased
property in a receiving zone,
the receiving zone designed to
increase density,
say in one of these urban
centers that I just mentioned,
then the developer that wanted
to increase the density of land
that he owned or would buy in
that urban zone would go to the
bank and purchase the credit so
that the adjacent landowner to
the turbine would be compensated
and development would be
encouraged to grow near existing
infrastructure.
So the ecosystem service banks
that have grown up associated
with wetlands,
degradation also with stream
mitigation banking,
they present I think a real
model for us to follow in the
future.
The SO_2 cap and
trade program was clearly a
success in reducing sulfur
dioxides and acid precipitation.
And a variety of other cases
that we went through in the
course I think also demonstrate
the potential effectiveness of
law.
The nuclear weapons testing ban
back in 1963.
Population control.
If this were Earth Day back in
1970, I remember the lectures on
Earth Day back in 1970,
and they were about population
control.
Population was thought to be
the source of environmental
degradation, particularly in the
developing world.
And population control efforts
have been really quite
successful.
We haven't discussed population
control.
And I'm actually a little
embarrassed to be running an
environmental studies major
without a demography element to
it.
But it really is a very
important aspect of
environmental degradation.
In terms of--and as the father
of children, I could think of
myself as having created with my
wife beautiful young children.
I could also think of it as
creating future consumers that
are going to be spending
millions of dollars buying goods
and services and developing land
and doing whatever that would
have an adverse effect on the
environment.
So that the mantra back in 1970
was population control is the
primary approach that we should
be taking to control
environmental damage.
The success in pesticides
associated with the chlorinated
hydrocarbons,
DDT, aldrin,
dieldrin, chemicals that would
bioaccumulate.
We really learned the
bioaccumulation story
predominantly from strontium-90
back in the weapons testing era.
But then it was repeated in the
1960s and 1970s.
And these compounds were
successfully phased out.
It was one of the first
objectives of William
Ruckelshaus when he became the
first administrator to the
Environmental Protection Agency.
And you can see in the graphs
the steady decline in
concentrations,
not just in birds but in fish
and other wildlife,
as well as in human tissues.
A great success story.
And that also was modeled in
the history of lead.
And as lead was taken out of
gasoline, as lead was taken out
of paint.
You can see the concentrations
declining and the nations
children and in other nations
where lead was removed.
It's really a very striking
success story.
Chlorinated fluorocarbons,
known to adversely affect the
stratospheric ozone layer were
removed from aerosols.
PCBs were removed from
transmission tower coolers and
other electronics,
they also had built up and
bioaccumulated in wildlife as
well as human tissues.
The prevention of use of
asbestos as a building material.
Our tobacco regulations.
We have one of the lowest
adoption rates now than has
existed at any other point
previous in the twentieth
century.
And food safety.
You may think of food safety as
kind of an odd topic,
but in low-income parts of the
world, food safety is a major
source of illness.
And even in this country,
the estimate by the Centers for
Disease Control of the number of
illnesses per year experienced
by contaminated food is
seventy-six million.
That's an enormous issue.
It has to do with the
availability of water and the
control of microbes and the way
that food is handled and washed
and stored as well as how it's
cooked.
The organic food movement has
been successful.
It's, as I mentioned earlier,
the most rapidly growing sector
in the food industry.
And drinking water quality.
Poor drinking water quality in
low-income parts of the world is
a major killer.
The World Health Organization
estimates that well more than a
million children die from
contaminated water each year.
We also suffer much less from
respiratory infections.
So forgive me as the computer
for some reason is running
through each one very slowly.
Come on.
So in contrast to where law has
worked well, where has it not
worked well?
Well I think fossil fuel policy
has been disastrous,
especially the kinds of
subsidies that we've allowed the
industry to receive.
And I mentioned that simply the
absence of investment in public
transit and the enormity of the
public investment in highway
development and highway
maintenance.
Our renewable energy policy has
also been a disaster.
And despite the improvements
and the increase in funding
that's going into renewable
energy,
it's nowhere near sufficient in
order to increase the proportion
of renewable energy that is
necessary to deal with the
CO_2 problem that we
face.
Personal consumption,
individual consumption,
individual purchasing is going
up, as are the number of people
in the country.
We're at about 310 million
people,
we're projected to go to about
350 in about the next forty
years and perhaps reach 400
million people in the nation.
So you multiply consumption of
each individual times that
scale, we're sitting in a nation
now where we have roughly 250
million automobiles.
And we're likely to see that
rise quite substantially.
So that people have fled to the
suburbs.
Now they can't sell the
property in the suburbs,
even if they wanted to live in
an urban area,
because of the declining land
value.
Parks and protected areas are
not being created any longer,
so that the rate of adoption of
parks and protected areas,
even though I just claimed that
they were a great success where
they were created,
the rate of establishing parks
and protect areas has fallen off
quite dramatically since that
time.
The Park Service's land
acquisition efforts have
declined.
Biological diversity loss is
also increasing as a function of
habitat loss,
as a function of chemical
applications,
pesticide applications.
Marine species exploitation is
increasing.
The rate of extinction is
increasing in the world's
oceans,
driven in part by changing
water quality in the coastal
zone,
but driven also by unregulated
fishing,
particularly beyond the
200-mile limit.
The outdoor as opposed to
indoor focus of the
Environmental Protection Agency
has been a serious problem.
If you gave me a sample of your
blood,
of your urine,
of your hair,
and we went down to CDC and had
it tested,
we would find a variety of
chemicals that come from the
built environment.
So that the absence of
attention to where we spend our
time, which is indoors,
is important.
There was a new study that was
just released that announced
that the average amount of time
spent by the nation's children
outdoors is now forty-two
minutes per week.
The average amount of time that
children now spent in front of
electronic media is now
fifty-two hours per week.
So there's something to that
statistic that is worth paying a
lot of attention to.
I'm here because my dad took me
hiking when I was a kid.
He took me to parks.
We'd hang out by streams.
He'd take me down to the beach.
But this is an increasingly
rare experience,
as people are spending more
time indoors and more time
staring at electronic equipment.
Hazardous sites;
we are adding the number of
hazardous sites to the lists
maintained by the government,
the federal government and
state governments every year.
So that we're not restoring
more than we're adding.
And this is a very serious
problem.
And the lessons of Vieques,
the long amount of time,
the enormous resources
necessary to clean these
facilities up,
now you should think about
that.
In five years,
in six years as you think about
where you want to live,
where you're going to rent a
house or an apartment.
You think about where you want
to buy a house or buy land,
you should pay a lot of
attention to the land use
history in these areas so that
you can be sure that you're
buying land that was not
formerly a disposal site.
Chemicals in commerce,
plastics in our bodies,
and product labeling is really
one of the weakest among the
higher income nations in the
world.
Another key issue that I'll
talk about a little bit more in
a minute is what I call
narrative advantage.
And if you think of the variety
of different sources of our
confusion about what to buy,
how to behave,
what energy consumption is
associated with the purchase of
an apple as opposed to a
hamburger.
As you think about how much we
don't know,
think also about how much what
we do know and how our
impressions are created by the
narrative advantage of the
powerful.
The narrative advantage of the
corporations as well as
government, so that they are
basically framing the issue
about what's worth worrying
about.
I wanted to also say that we
did not have a chance to talk
much about CO_2
trading programs.
But we have a very active and
important one ongoing right here
in Connecticut as we're part of
a ten-state plan to reduce
CO_2 emissions from
the power plants in this region.
And this was adopted as law in
nine of these states,
but not in New York.
And it's interesting that one
energy company,
the Indeck Energy Company,
sued the State of New York for
creating cap and trade
regulations with no statutory
authority.
So could New York establish cap
and trade regulations and impose
it on the utilities in its state
without statutory authority?
So this case is still pending.
The other states have adopted
this approach.
So that for all the utilities
or for the largest utilities
that contribute CO_2
in this region,
there has been a ceiling that
has been established.
And between now and 2012,
the ceiling will be stable and
then it will decline as total
amount of CO_2 emitted
that's allowable will be reduced
and they will have to retrofit,
they will have to fuel switch
in order to figure out how
they're going to meet that
ceiling.
It's a very important approach.
So if you think back on what
are the key problems with our
broad body of environmental law,
well, it's fractured by
problem.
It's fractured by media,
by air, water,
food, consumer products.
And often these problems
evolved case by case and
motivated political action in
individual states or motivated
the legislators in those
individual states to approach
Congress and suggest that this
is an example of a problem that
exists in every state,
we should pass national law to
address it.
But each law is set up very
differently.
It was not set up based upon a
certain set of overriding
guiding principles such as exist
in the European Union.
And I'm going to make a few
comparisons in a few moments to
European environmental law by
contrast.
It's fractured by level of
government,
so we have law that is
established by local
governments,
state governments and the
federal government that is often
incompatible,
and it's extremely confusing
for those that want to develop,
such as the wind turbine farm,
Cape Wind up in Massachusetts.
It's a classic example of
regulatory confusion and the
litigation and delay and cost
that ensues.
We have little surveillance at
the scale that's relevant to the
individual,
and something that we have not
spoken about that's really
important is that environmental
monitoring responsibilities and
surveillance responsibilities
have largely been delegated to
those that are regulated over
the past several decades by the
Environmental Protection Agency.
So that's an interesting idea.
I mean, if you are say the
maker of benzene,
you are responsible to report
your benzene emissions from your
smokestacks to the Environmental
Protection Agency.
There's no one else that is
independent that monitors it.
Or is there no monitoring
equipment that reports directly
to the Environmental Protection
Agency.
So thinking about the way that
the surveillance system is set
up is really critical to the
long-term effectiveness of
environmental law.
The next point is the pace of
regulation.
And I just mentioned the pace
of litigation a few moments ago.
The pace of regulation is often
slower than litigation.
So that you would want a system
ideally to be responsive to
newfound evidence of risk.
So supposing I found that
chemical X in the food supply is
exceptionally dangerous and
people are highly exposed and
they've got it in their tissues.
Well, following that discovery
and following a consensus among
scientists that that is a
significant threat,
it normally takes ten to
fifteen, and I've seen twenty
years with respect to
pesticides,
before the government responds
and then changes the regulation
to lower the allowable use of
the chemical or sets a different
ceiling on it.
And this basically-- law has
the effect then of providing a
false sense of security when you
think,
my gosh, we have three dozen
statutes in place,
we must be reasonably well
protected as a society.
Well, I think after this
course, you will be more
skeptical.
It's difficult and costly to
measure effectiveness.
And when ineffectiveness is
found, agencies are not happy
about that.
So that that's why we have a
Government Accountability Office
that commonly will look at the
behavior of agencies and whether
or not the statute is achieving
the Congressionally mandated
intent.
Our law system is highly
specialized in the sciences,
and it often takes scientific
training at a graduate level in
order to be able to debate about
the appropriateness of certain
standards.
Similarly, if you're arguing
about the effect of human
development on endangered
species habitat,
it takes expertise and biology,
often at the graduate level,
to get a seat at the table.
So think about that.
If you're considering a future
in environmental management of
one sort or another,
think about how you might shore
up your technical capacity.
It's highly centralized in
decision-making.
It's really difficult in order
to participate in decision
making at the federal level of
government.
There are action channels and
there are groups of people that
are well known to the regulators
that play a disproportionate
role in making choices that have
a much more highly distributed
effect.
So I'm not going to go through
all these different kinds of
decision standards,
but we've touched on a variety
of different approaches to
setting standards in different
laws.
Remember the federal
Insecticide, Fungicide,
and Rodenticide Act at the top
here.
It was a risk-benefit balancing
law.
Think about the Food,
Drug and Cosmetic Act as it
applies to drugs.
That's a risk-risk tradeoff law.
So that a doctor prescribes the
drug to you because the doctor
thinks that although there may
be a risk of a side effect,
that the benefit to you is
higher, it's more significant
than the side effect risk.
Cost-benefit analysis is
another form of decision-making
analysis that is often demanded
in environmental law.
Risk ceilings,
acceptable risk levels.
I've seen acceptable risk
levels for cancer-causing agents
in the environment that vary
between one excess cancer is
allowable per thousand people
exposed as opposed to a standard
that would allow,
a California standard,
one excess risk in a million
people exposed.
And I've seen other proposals
for one in ten million.
So that the idea of acceptable
risk is quite variable,
and it can have an enormous
effect on the allowable
concentration of a compound out
there in the environment.
The sustainable yield
definition, there's the
Multiple-Use and Sustainable
Yield Act that applies to the
U.S.
Forest Service.
And this is a really
interesting idea as well.
But it's technical.
So that one would have to look
at a national forest and figure
out how much timber it normally
produces,
how much could be harvested
without adversely affecting the
sustained yield at that level.
So being able to identify the
sustained yield and to develop
an understanding of how you go
into an area and you get the
timber out without depleting the
soil resources say of organic
matter,
water holding capacity,
that's a technical issue.
Density restrictions,
land use segregation,
disclosure and transparency
requirements,
certification requirements
inside the Food Production Act.
The reasonable certainty of no
harm standard in the Food
Quality Protection Act is the
most rigid health protective
standard that we've got in the
United States.
It's as health protective as
any statute also in the European
Union.
And also technological
feasibility.
So what's feasible now as
opposed to technology forcing
standards that would demand that
industry say,
lower their auto emissions down
to a level that's not possible
now,
but you give them a ceiling and
say that you've got five years
to reach that reduced ceiling.
Restricting false claims of
benefit or demanding expression
of risk, so product labeling.
And then restoration standards
that exist inside the Resource
Conservation and Recovery Act
and the Superfund law.
So that there are different
forms of standards,
different decision making
criteria and analyses across
these laws.
I wanted to compare for just a
couple of minutes some key
principles of law.
So I just said that U.S.
law has evolved incrementally
in a patchwork quilt fashion
with a variety of these
different standards that were in
the last slide.
How about European law?
Well, European law evolved
based upon a collection of
principles, principles that are
not embedded in all of our laws.
So we have no law in our
country that basically forces
the statute to comply with
principles such as exist in the
EU law.
One is a high level of
protection is demanded,
but not the highest.
And this would force the
definition of what high means,
and it has and it's produced
litigation.
The precautionary principle
that despite uncertainty in the
effect of timber harvesting on
endangered species habitat or of
a chemical on human health,
despite the uncertainty,
it is a better idea to be
precautionary,
to set a standard that would be
protective.
And this is quite similar to
another principal that they call
the prevention principle,
that prevention is better than
the cure.
And they also have the source
principle, that a problem should
be managed at its source,
rather than down the road.
So you know,
if you have a nasty pesticide,
are you going to manage that
pesticide by allowing farmers to
use it and then going out and
monitoring its presence in the
water supply or in the foods
that you eat?
That's managing at the
downstream level,
as opposed to at the source.
So nip it in the bud.
If it's a really dangerous
chemical, prohibit it or don't
allow it to be used under
certain circumstances.
The polluter pays principle
that dictates that polluters are
financially responsible for the
pollution that they emit from
their smokestacks,
from their pipe,
their waterline discharge
points,
and that they are also
responsible for damages.
And they're responsible for
coming up to solutions to the
problem that they're creating.
And also, that they are open to
liability claims.
And finally,
the safeguard principle that
member states in the European
Union have the authority to
adopt tougher laws given their
particular conditions.
Now, when I say that,
I know that these seem like
they're kind of dry principles.
But when I say that,
the bell that should be going
off in your head is a bell about
preemption and how important it
is to think carefully about
when,
under what circumstance do you
want to preempt a lower level of
government,
say France, from adopting a
tougher level of regulation than
the European Union?
Or when do you want to have
California be given the
authority to adopt tougher air
quality regs as opposed to those
that are established by EPA?
So that the safeguard principle
cuts across all European law
that gives the member nations
the authority to set standards
that are tougher than the
Union's.
I want to talk just a couple of
minutes about poverty and the
environment.
And we haven't spent much time
on that during the course.
But the impoverished in the
world generally face degraded
environmental conditions
compared to the more wealthy.
And these are often ignored by
governments.
Exposures to hazards are
normally higher.
The poorest are left to the
most marginal lands.
It's kind of interesting to
watch what happens in a town,
even in Connecticut,
when developers have built on
all of the really nice lands,
and then you have the old down
dump,
the landfill,
that nobody wanted to live near
and remained undeveloped.
But as the towns reach build
out, meaning that all the other
lands have been developed to the
zoning density limit,
then increasingly,
you see lower income people
moving into those areas.
There was the Bhopal,
India chemical release back in
1984 that killed tens of
thousands of people and injured
hundreds of thousands of others.
Those people had basically
migrated next to the chemical
company and set up camps that
made them immediately adjacent
to the edge of the chemical
company.
And that history,
I encourage you to take a look
at it.
The chemical release of methyl
isocyanate killed or injured
people in a matter of several
hours because they were so close
to the plant,
there was no buffer zone to it.
So the poor tend not to have
access to capital.
They tend not to have insurance.
They tend not to have the
capacity to understand and to
manage risk the way that the
wealthy do.
Healthcare surveillance is
something that they cannot
afford.
And litigation is rarely an
opportunity.
So as you think about the
relationship between
environmental problems and the
fascination and the drive that
our nation has to grow,
to produce more,
to consume more,
to become wealthier,
I want you to think more
carefully about this.
I want you to think about
whether or not this fascination
with growth,
of bigger is better,
really is something that we
need to confront more directly.
The ethical effects of pursuing
more, more wealth,
really have a variety of
dimensions.
So that as you think about your
own behavior,
your own pattern of
consumption, if you think about
whether or not you really need
that next iPod,
the next iPhone,
or the next iPhone app.
If you think about the kinds of
foods you want to buy in the
marketplace and you start
thinking about these as ethical
choices and about how they may
cause a distributional pattern
of costs and benefits out in
ways that may not be easily
identified.
So as wealth increases,
the opposite argument might go,
so do the following.
Control over modes of
production, control over labor
and providing labor with certain
rights that they might not have
had so wealthier nations tend to
have higher protective standards
for labor.
They have higher standards for
the control of materials.
There's another mode of
production, component of the
mode of production,
as well as regulations on the
use of capital.
And the wealthier nations in
the world also have more control
and accountability that's
demanded of government.
They have higher education,
higher capacity to identify
risk.
And as wealth increases,
environmental controls,
regulations become more
sophisticated,
as does the capacity to buy
insurance,
access to health care,
and the capacity to select
risks and avoid them.
So one idea,
thinking about whether or not
there is a trickle-down effect.
So as the world becomes
wealthier, as the high income
nations become wealthier,
is there going to be a
trickle-down effect,
or should we systematically
think about how we might
redistribute wealth,
knowledge, authority and a
sense of a collective ethic?
And will this be a stairway to
improved environmental quality
and human health?
I wanted to just mention too,
and emphasize this idea once
more of narrative advantage and
how critical it is,
given the scale of money that's
being put into advertising.
So half a trillion dollars per
year in the world going into
advertising,
promoting products,
promoting economic growth and
making claims about product
benefits and normally not fully
disclosing what product risks or
product long-term damages might
be.
We talked on many occasions in
the course about the idea of
ignorance as being an underlying
source for environmental
problems.
So I don't mean ignorance in a
demeaning way at all.
I don't mean it to infer the
absence of capacity.
I mean it to infer the absence
of knowledge or the incapacity
to develop that knowledge but
for no reason of personal
problem, personal incapacity.
So what are the underlying
sources?
Well, illiteracy is clearly one
of them.
Secrecy is another,
deception is another,
privacy is another,
language barriers.
But I'm increasingly fascinated
by the idea that legal control
of knowledge in the form of
trade secrecy and classified
information are really critical
targets that we need to manage
more effectively in order to
create a literate society that
might be able to participate in
markets as well as in government
decision-making in ways that
will lead us to a more health
protective,
environmentally responsible
future.
So secrecy has a very insidious
and negative effect.
And we've seen it in a variety
of cases.
It concentrates knowledge among
those with authority and power.
It actually is a form of social
control.
So if I have knowledge and I
withhold for you because it
basically will prevent you from
being able to compete with me,
then that basically is a form
of-- its authority,
it's power for me to be able to
control you.
Secrecy inhibits public
intelligence,
and it enhances the persuasive
power of elites,
again providing narrative
advantage.
Throughout the course,
across all of these cases,
I have mentioned the importance
of looking at distributional
effects and avoiding what I call
here the veil of averages.
If you allow yourself to be
convinced of arguments based
upon statistical claims of the
effect on average is going to be
X,
or even the benefits on average
are going to be Y,
then you should not do that.
You should think much more
carefully and deeply about
distributional patterns in
society.
How is risk distributed?
How are benefits distributed?
Is there an overlap among the
risks and the benefits?
Do we want to structure law in
a way that encourages that to be
transparent and overlapped?
So I'm going to close here,
and I'm going to just take a
little bit of license,
and I apologize for this,
because you may think of me as
being paternal.
But this class represents,
I believe, a class where I've
now taught about 2,500 Yale
students.
And this has given me a
perspective on the success of my
students as I watch them down
the road.
What careers they take,
how they come back and want
recommendations.
But also want to let me know
that they're taking some ideas
into their future.
So what advice could I give you?
Well, I would encourage you to
think really carefully about
what drives you morally.
What are your dominant moral
values?
And I've got kids your age.
I say that to them,
"Give me your top five
dominant moral values.
And learn to understand how
those values might guide your
behaviors."
And in my life,
I've often concluded that boy,
if I'd just listened to that
inner voice that would have told
me what the right thing to do
was and it would have been a
better decision.
So learn to trust your
instincts about what's really
important in your life.
It's not just about getting
richer.
Learn yourself and then teach
others.
You're at one of the most
prestigious and one of the best
educational institutions in the
world and it's just such an
incredible privilege for you to
be here.
But I think now about it,
the educational experience that
you're getting,
not in my course,
but in better courses,
as a privilege,
as something that really you
have an obligation to carry on,
to expand the knowledge of
other people.
Lead by example.
Don't just tell people what to
do.
People see you being focused
and disciplined and taking on
the toughest and meanest and
nastiest and dirtiest jobs,
they're going to respect that
and they're going to follow you.
So focus and discipline is
really a key to success.
I would encourage you to reduce
your access, your reliance on
electronic media.
I see students walking down the
road holding their cell phones
in front of them,
no conversations at all.
I mean, the value of
conversation is enormous
compared to the value of
communication via electronic
media.
Body language,
understanding how emotion and
rationality are mixed up in
language.
You don't get that from
Twitter, you don't get that from
emailing people.
So I'd encourage you to think
carefully about the amount of
time that you spend your life in
that way.
I worry a lot about what's
going to happen in future
generations because of the way
that your generation and those
younger are spending their time.
Not going out,
not experiencing the wild,
not experiencing the natural.
I mean, I can't imagine that
people would have the passion to
care about the wild and the
natural or the pure,
the chemical free,
if they had not experienced it
themselves.
And that's the reason that I
take my classes out to the
Adirondacks.
Or I've taken them to Wyoming
or to other places,
because many people just don't
have that experience.
They were not lucky enough to
have the experience I had when I
was a kid.
Consume what you need.
Think really carefully about
what you need.
And how much space do you need?
My argument with Kroon Hall,
how much cubic feet of space do
you really need per person in
Kroon Hall as I look up at that
forty-foot high ceiling.
Yes, it's grand.
Architecturally,
it's a wonderful esthetic
experience.
But in the new age of being
concerned about energy
consumption and renewables,
is that a luxury that we can
really afford?
Know what you're consuming.
If anything,
you should walk away from this
course being skeptical about
this issue.
It's hard to do.
What's in your environment?
What do you need to protect
yourself against?
Drive less.
Self-propel yourself more.
It's not only good for the
climate, it's great for your
health.
You'll remember the design of
that Centers for Disease Control
building, specifically designed
with that staircase that is
beautiful.
A beautiful staircase with
light glass panes going up the
side of the stairwell that
encourages everybody to get to
their office up on the seventh
or eighth floor by walking up
the steps as opposed to taking
the elevator that's in the back
of the building.
Become politically active
regardless of your party.
Show up.
It's really pretty remarkable,
and I hesitate to say this in a
class where I know a bunch of
you have not shown up all the
time.
But a lot of success is
involved in the social
relationships that you develop
just by showing up and paying
attention.
You know, I have thought long
and hard whether or not I wanted
to adopt Harvard Law School's
prohibition of the use of
laptops in the classroom,
and I've decided not to do that.
So I mean, I figure that if I
can't engage you in a lecture,
and if I regulate your use of
laptop, then I shouldn't
regulate it.
But I also feel that those of
you that are not paying
attention, you know,
there are probably some pretty
good reasons for it.
And the most important lesson I
think I have for you is to be
confident about yourself.
And I want you to think about
this one really carefully
because my belief is really that
you wouldn't be here at Yale if
you did not have the capacity to
change the world.
Now, you know how many Yale
leaders have had enormous
influence in corporations,
in government,
in the nonprofit community.
So that capacity,
it's an enormous gift.
And I'll leave you with one
final reflection is that you may
think it's really hard to induce
change in the world,
but it's not.
It's really not.
If you demonstrate your
passion, you develop the
knowledge, you develop a
coalition, you can make change
at any level of government.
So be confident about yourself
and go in peace.
So thank you very much for a
great term.